first of all you got to work on your
stamina talk i would destroy you even
before you discovered carbs
trust the process trust the process
trust them
welcome to the arena outside of space
and time where we play 101 win by two on
one side we have 20 21's joelle and bean
all in
man i had a good card versus 1991
charles barkley the battle of the tough
guys hey no more i get it i watch
cartoons
[Applause]
oh you look mad as hell did i spit on
your kid
for me fam feeler what the hell happened
to delphi blame me i need to prove to
future you that i am better man get off
me soft serve elijah wine
[Music]
barkley is
he unmovable a tough mate away
and chuck proves that you can't measure
hard in inches hey robot mark valverde
can't put money on this game once he
drives he may just get his own rebounds
oh man this is like seeing old photos of
your dad
look what white people from the internet
talk to me what the hell is the internet
don't y'all have guards not
really my god this guy's less of a role
model than me don't look don't look
barkley is just relentless right now
excuse me
he slams at home too weak the round
turn it off
and then b can beat america's uncle
right now
no man could back me down i am not a man
i am a chore
he's starting to play like a big man
he can beat at least one third of the
guys in a capital one ass
charles you taught me how to be a big
man do you remember why do you think
i've been so hard on you i love you
charles barkley
[Music]
this is so fun i'm definitely
subscribing for more
oh god we're on the kiss cam i
guess we should just get it over with
i
don't think of you that way
you know they should do mj versus lebron
next should have taken my brother